this needs oscar-winning animation
Beauty and the Beast is often considered
one of the studio's best still over the
years fans have analyzed the film and
uncovered numerous movie mistakes goofs
and plot holes yippee-ki-yay movie
lovers it's Jan here and in this video
I'll be explaining how Disney's
live-action remake of Beauty and the
Beast fixes many of those mistakes and
just before I get stuck in be warned
there are spoilers ahead for both movies
to avoid them you can tap or click here
to watch my spoiler free review of
Beauty and the Beast and come back when
you've seen the film's now I invite you
to relax and pull up a chair as I
proudly present 10 mistakes goofs and
potholes fixed by the new Beauty and the
Beast movie bookworm Belle seem to have
a curious arrangement with a bookseller
in her village if she didn't appear to
actually buy any books from him instead
she borrowed books freely whenever she
wanted something to read
making his bookshop more of a library
than an actual business the new movie
cleverly fixes this by having Belle
borrow her books from the local priest
para ver and acknowledges the original
movie mistake by having her thank him
with the words your library makes our
small corner of the world feel big in
fact it's absurd as a bookshop at all in
the original film given how much all the
townspeople hate reading and it's a
callback to this inconsistency when para
Behr refers to Belle as the only
bookworm in town you might have enjoyed
watching Gaston fall into a muddy pond
after Belle fended off his advances in
the animated movie however the way it
happened really doesn't make sense what
I mean is that he falls out of Belle's
door straight into the muddy pond
however the pond isn't anywhere near
Belle's house so that couldn't actually
happen this time around Gaston doesn't
fall into a pond but he does step into a
muddy puddle just after Belle robust him
outside her home and notice that the
filmmakers located that muddy puddle a
little way down the street from Belle's
house very likely in recognition of that
funny incongruous moment in the original
movie the time period to the original
Beauty in the Beast was never officially
confirmed by Disney but to close the
type of gun Gaston uses and the use of
steam powered machinery by Maurice
suggests the likely time period is the
1790s or early 1800s now that means that
the eiffel tower which appears during be
our guest is an anachronism because
construction only began on it in 1887
the new movie makes a very funny
Chintu this original movie mistake as it
replaces the Eiffel Tower and be our
guest with a guillotine joke when
Lumiere chops baguette into the
guillotine would have been historically
accurate for the animated movie because
this form of execution was introduced in
France during the French Revolution in
1792 which fits into the likely time
period when the animation was said
curiously though Lumias youthful
guillotine joke may have introduced a
new movie mistake into the live-action
version because as I just mentioned the
guillotine wasn't common in France until
the late 18th century
whereas Disney estate is that the remake
is actually set in the mid 18th century
by the way chopping the baguette may
also be a little knowing joke by the
filmmakers about how they cut the line
we read of a guest from the new movie
talking of timelines
there's a significant plot hole heavily
implied in the animated movie in that
film Lumiere revealed that the castle
has been under the Enchantress's spell
for ten years and the narration at the
beginning of the film explains that the
prince had until a 21st birthday to
break the spell or the curse would
become permanent if we do the maths and
subtract ten years and 21 this suggests
that the prince would have been around
11 at the time of the curse but the
painting we see the B flash is one of
him as an adult man which doesn't make
sense that he was cursed as a child the
new movie neatly fixes this issue in a
couple of ways firstly we see that the
prince is already an adult when the
Enchantress curses him and secondly
Lumias line and be our guest changes
from 10 years we've been rusting too too
long we've been rusting the ages of Chip
and mrs. Potts in the animated movie
have also been questioned by fans in
that movie chips voice sounds younger
than 10 years old and he also looks very
young when he transforms into human form
which imply he was born a teacup this
crazy thought has born theories about
whether mrs. Potts the teapot could
actually have given birth to a teacup
while enchanted also when she's in a
human form mrs. Potts looks somewhat old
bishop's mother these age problems are
fixed in the remake because the
filmmakers made a point of including a
scene where mrs. Potts and Chip run into
the ballroom as the princess being
cursed meaning that we know they both
existed in their human forms before the
curse was enacted the new movie also
makes a joke about the idea that mrs.
Potts was perhaps rather old to be chips
mother in the original
movies this happens when the Fuu ask
mrs. Potts the cheese chips
grandmother which infuriates her she
kicks off the attack by the enchanted
object on the villages invading the
castle and there's another mrs. Potts GU
fixed from the animation during be our
guest you'll need to look carefully but
notice that when mrs. Potts is's her
iconic line heaven's sake is that a spot
this time she cleans off a dirty spot on
chip but watch the animation carefully
just before this moment and you'll see
that even though mrs. Potts hops around
all over the place and we get to see her
all over there was never a spot on her
at any point until she says that line in
the film the new movie gives proper time
on screen to The Enchantress with new
details and clarification of how the
curse works helping to explain away
other plot holes and the animated
version for example in the original
movie it seems silly that the local town
was totally unaware of the nearby castle
this is fixed in the Enchantress's new
narration she explains that her curse
made everyone in the town forget to the
castle and the servants who live there
ever existed when Maurice can't figure
out which way to go in the original film
it seems like an overwhelmingly foolish
choice to take the fork in the road that
leads down a dark and Misty foreboding
past maurices horse de leak really
doesn't want to go down that way either
but the animation uses his master's poor
choice to set up an accident where
Maurice get separated from Philippe and
ends up later at the beasts castle the
new movie has a much better take on this
in keeping with its story as a lightning
strike causes a tree to block maurices
usual path which then forces him to take
the alternate more ominous looking path
when Philippe returns home to Balan the
animation he appears to know how to take
her to beasts hidden castle this makes
no sense because Philippe had never been
to the castle before having bolted
before Maurice ever got to the beasts
enchanted home in the new film maurice
ends up at the castle with philippe so
now it makes more sense that the horse
would be able to direct Valda in both
movies beast comes to Belle's rescue and
she's attacked by wolves after trying to
flee the castle and in both cases he
gets badly injured the animation however
skips over her bowel managed to lift the
unconscious an enormous ly heavy beast
onto her horse the new movie has a nice
subtle remedy to this problem when Belle
goes to the injured
system says to him you have to help me
you have to stand because it's clear
that there's no way Bell will be able to
lift the huge beast by herself without
his help so what do you think of
Disney's Beauty and the Beast remake and
how well do you think it's fixed any
problems with the original also did you
spot any new movie mistake scoops or
plot holes in a new movie do let me know
in the comments below and if you enjoyed
this I'd really appreciate it if you hit
that like button and while you're here
check out my full beauty in the beasts
playlist with Easter egg videos secrets
about the making of the movie and my
breakdown of the differences between the
1991 and 2017 movies
Capel click here to check those out and
subscribe to get notified about all my
upcoming new Disney and beauty in the
Beast videos thanks for watching and see
you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers